estas elecciones han llevado a una nueva
generación a la vanguardia de la vida
política de Turquía estos jóvenes tienen
18 años nacieron en los primeros días
del gobierno de erdogan y no han
conocido otro gobernante asisten a una
escuela musulmana algo que ardugan hizo
posible en Turquía rechazando lo que él
consideraba como el gobierno laicista y
elitista
no sentimos parte de una gran familia
con erdogan liderándonos a nivel mundial
después de todo lo que ha hecho por el
islam pero las grandes ciudades cuentan
una historia diferente este barrio de
Estambul es un bastión de erdogan pero
en medio de una crisis económica la
elección ya no es tan sencilla como
antes
allí Perdona ha hecho mucho por nuestro
país pero su gestión ya no es la misma
sus políticas ya no funcionan y es hora
de cambiar
y en la universidad de Estambul la
oposición a erdogan florece estas
jóvenes hacen campaña para los derechos
de la mujer y las libertades políticas
dice que liberen a todas las presas
políticas y esta dice que tienes un
lugar en este colectivo de mujeres
recuerdan una protesta en 2021 en la que
dos de ellas fueron detenidas
no estaba bien estaba ejerciendo mi
derecho básico a protestar y Mostrar mi
descontento con una decisión del
presidente
tras 20 años bajo un único gobierno
estos activistas creen que ha llegado la
hora del cambio dicen que sierdogan gana
intentarán abandonar el país